- Dès lundi, le plus haut
la Cour d'appel du Québec
entendra les arguments pour
et contre la Loi québécoise sur
la laïcité de l'État; la Loi 21.
PATRICK TAILLON, profess U U U l
- Ça, ça sera en quelque sorte,
unèèèès dans le procès.
Un appel dans l'appel.
Le débat entourant la question
nationale, il y aura aussi
la question mmmmmmmmissions
scolaires anglophones.
English Montreal, on a
l'intention de se battre
des enseignantes jusqu'en
Cour suprême, s'il le faut.
scolaire English Montreal
- Pour nous, ce n'est pas
une enseignante dans
une classe qui porte
ça démontre de la diversité.
- Le Mouvement laïque québécois
Son objectif est q la loi
s'applique à l'ensemble
des travailleurs en pos s s s se
publique, soit les enseignants,
les policiers et les juges.
- Que la loi 21 s'applique
pour l'ensemble.tttttttttttttttt
Mouvement laïque québécois
- Il exiaiaiaiairement
en droit constitutionnel
canadien un devoir de
les représentants de l'État.
- Liberté! Liberté!
- Dès le départ, en 2019,
la Loi 21 avait été adoptée
dans la contro1,1,1,1,1,1,1,1,1t
de la Cour supérieure du Québecs
scolaires anglophones et
les élus de l'Assemblée
Selon le juge Marc-André
Blanchard :
Le gouvernement du Québec
enururururururururururururururue
à tous ceux visés par
la loi, sans exception.
- Il n'y a pas deux Québec,
- La bataille entre Québec
etpppppppposants à la Loi 21
est loin d'être terminée.
a déjà annoncé son intention
de se joindre à la contestation
de la Loi 21 si le dossieru'u'u.
Ici Gabrielle Proulx,
Radio-Canada, Montréa